today's schedule with a pedagogical talk
so one of the few
silver linings in this fallen world of
ours is
having virtual talks from people who
would not normally be able to attend so
i'm very pleased
to have amin here to tell us about
random optimization problems i'm not
sure what part of the large landscape of
his work he's going to tell us about but
um i'm looking forward to it thanks for
being here i mean
yeah thank you chris thanks to the
organizers for the invitation this is my
first time
uh speaking at the simon's institute i
mean
not really at but maybe to the simon's
institute or maybe to an audience that
is connected via a zoom account of the
simon's institute
uh nonetheless it's a great pleasure to
be here um
i was asked to give one of these
pedagogical talks and i suppose that
is hint by the organizers to the speaker
that
you're getting on a little bit um and
so i'm in fact not going to have
much new to say i mean i'm going to
mention a few recent results but
most of the work that i'm going to
present is not even my own
nonetheless i didn't manage to include
all the relevant references so if one of
your favorite
references is missing please accept my
sincere apologies
i'm going to have two parts um about
random optimization problems the first
part is about
motivation so this is kind of me
rumbling
about stuff that i always wanted to tell
somebody but
nobody bothered to listen so
i'm going to share some of my ideas
about
random optimization problems in general
and in the second talk i'm going to
discuss some of the
recent or yeah more or less recent
physics-inspired techniques that
have advanced the state-of-the-art by
comparison to what we knew
a number of years ago so
let me begin with the motivation
part what are random optimization
problems what do i mean by a random
optimization problem
well i mean something like a minimum
spelling tree on a complete graph
with random weights or something like
the notorious planted clique problem
where somebody
inserts a biggish clique into an
otherwise
purely random graph or actually the
example that i'm going to speak about
most of the time
something like the maximum cut problem
on random graphs in fact i'm not going
to speak about
the first type of problem much i'm going
to focus on the latter two
which have the advantage of being
interesting also from a computational
perspective
as specimens of np-hard problems
uh so let me begin this motivation part
by telling you what i think random
optimization problems are not good for
and i'm going to try and debunk
something that i might call the average
case myth
so whenever i go to a general
conference the vulgar assumption seems
to be that
we study random optimization problems
because they are excellent
models of real-world examples or more
precisely because we believe that they
are excellent models of real world
instances and so maybe analyzing random
instances might tell us something about
the real world might suggest
new ways of coping with difficult real
real world problems
and um okay i simply believe that that's
not entirely true in fact that nothing
could be further from the truth
uh nonetheless let's say in the early
days when when np hardness was still
new a new concept
this was a compelling idea that you
could maybe somehow
model real world instances model reality
and then discover that hardness
is the exception that normally life is
good
and and the real world is a lot easier
than
complexity theory might suggest
of course as i died in the rule
pessimist um i don't think that
but um there's there's other people out
there too of course that might have a
more
positive slant on matters so
uh well there was a real phenomenon here
that
that
needed explaining namely why a lot of
times
uh real world instances of supposedly
hard problems
turn out to be relatively easy i mean
not as easy as a minimum spanning tree
problem maybe but nonetheless
people succeeded at solving pretty large
instances for example of the
satisfiability problem
and so one idea might be to use some
random model like for example the random
k-sub model
in order to describe such instances and
maybe you would discover that these are
easy and therefore we can use some
simple algorithm to also
deal with real-world instances um and
belts and whistles were added to this
concept
things like semi-random instances uh
smooth analysis which of course does
have is
its purpose and its justification for
example in the
setup where you get uh real numbers that
might be uh prone to errors prone to
gaussian arrows for example or the idea
for example that recently came up
of power law models of satisfiability
instances and so in fact like i said
there's some explaining here to be done
namely if you look at the set
competitions the most recent one
just happened this year in 2020 then you
see that people actually succeed at
solving pretty large instances
um something with 10 million variables
and 32 million clauses
qualifies as pretty large in my book
anyway
and there's there's been interesting
ideas like clause learning
and you can see in this diagram here
that
performance of such real-world
sub-solvers has been improving rather
significantly in the last
20 years so these bars
indicate the number of instances that
solvers can cope with in a
fixed amount of computation time and
this has increased about five-fold
in the last 20 years or so
and of course if you speak to people in
model checking
or vlsi design they will tell you that
once the problem
boils down to a satisfiability problem
we are at home we can
solve the problem we are essentially
done
okay that's that's wonderful now let's
see how does can can we use random cases
to explain this phenomenon does this
random case that explain why these
wonderful algorithms are so
exceedingly efficient and um
can we yeah is there some simple
algorithmic lessons to be learned from
random cases well actually no
so it has been known for a while now
that the satisfiability threshold
actually occurs
at a clause to variable density
in k set of about 2 to the k times
log 2. so up to this point we know
thanks to a non-constructive argument
thanks to
a second moment type of argument
effectively
that a randomly generated formula is
going to
have at least one satisfying assignment
in fact typically many satisfying
assignments
at the same time um all
known satisfiability algorithms actually
fail for
far lower densities for densities as low
as 2 to the k times log k over k so
about a factor
k below the satisfiability threshold in
other words
for most of the satisfiable regime
random instances
actually don't seem to be amenable to
efficient algorithms so
um in particular if you take one of
these industrial sub solvers
and hurl it at a random k-sub instance
or more precisely hold the random case
of instance at the algorithm
it is not going to do very well in fact
it's going to fail miserably
and um so
yeah in my opinion this kind of yeah so
there's a discrepancy here between
what randomness seems to do and what
happens
in the real world so um
why why is it that these random real
world
that these real world instances are easy
well the reason seems to be that they
are
quite structured to be more precise
when i when i spoke to these sub-solving
community
researchers i found that i discovered
that actually
they have a different slant on
complexity than
many of us do namely they don't have
this model in mind where you have
an algorithm and this algorithm
gets confronted with a separate
potentially very large instance
but their view is that actually the
instances and the algorithms
co-evolve so you
try and design algorithms and instances
together so that they fit
so when they reduce problems to casert
they try to
perform the reduction in such a way that
the
resulting formula is easy
for the particular kind of subserver
that they have at their disposal
um and of course this kind of structure
this kind of low entropy structure is
absent from
random instances random instances are if
anything
maximum entropy so they have as little
local specific structure as you can
imagine
and even if you add your bells and
whistles like semi-random
instances smooth analysis or these
notorious power laws
that may or may not be present in real
world satisfiability instances for all i
know
the problem of axis entropy the fact
that you for example
contain a expander graph an excellent
expander
somewhere in your instance still
persists
and seems to decouple these random
models entirely
from the real world instances
and to put the cherry on top um it is
not only that
the random instances that we set out to
use to explain
why real world instances are easy are
poor models
they also turn to be rather difficult we
can't even solve them
so this idea of average case analysis
seemed to have failed seems to have
failed on every possible
count so
that granted what what reasons are there
to spend
the taxpayers money on random
optimization problems
um well one motivation might be the
probabilistic method
and in fact i think this is a very good
motivation so
when we learn something about random
optimization problems we can maybe
use that knowledge in order to design
um or in order to come up with
good designs of probabilistic
constructions
that can be used for specific purposes
in other words in examples where we can
actually
like in the set solving community
influence the instances that we are
asked to solve we can maybe use our
knowledge about
random instances a good example of this
is low density parity check codes or
generally speaking error correcting
codes
because in coding theory the design of
the parity check matrix of your code
is at your disposal it's up to you to
design
the check matrix and to design the type
of
combinatorial structure that you want to
work on
and maybe you can use a randomized
construction in order to
come up with an efficient algorithmic
solution
and this has been maybe in in
if you like our community or maybe my
community one of the showcase examples
um in my opinion of a successful
real world application namely low
density parity check codes that you
actually carry around with you
as part of modern communication
standards
the second a beautiful example is
compressed
sensing that you certainly have heard
about
and a third example that i personally
like partly because we
have been working on it is group testing
which is about a scenario that seemed
rather
outlandish at the time we looked at the
problem namely that a
new virus befalls mankind and
we are at a shortage of test
kits so that we have to pull samples in
order to
test as many individuals as possible
with a smaller number of tests
as possible and so this
is an example where actually the problem
of inferring of learning
the set of infected individuals from the
test results
boils down to a minimum hypergraph
vertex cover problem
that on a purely random hyper graph
might be difficult to solve but with a
specific
suitably tailored randomized
construction can be solved efficiently
by a
fairly sophisticated algorithm so
here we managed to solve a random
optimization problem
in a way that that can be used as a
device in a probabilistic construction
so in other words the probabilistic
method is one
salient motivation in my opinion to
study random optimization problems
a second one seems to be that
random optimization problems allow us a
glimpse at the nature of complexity in
some cases
so for example there's some beautiful
work on proof complexity
from a few years back that uses random
satisfiability formulas
there has been a lot of work also by
some people in the audience
on the planet clique problem and the
sums of squares hierarchy
and the k-side refutation problem has
been used in order to gain insight on
other on the complexity of other
problems
and david and others have been doing
amazing work on the overlap
gap property and lower bounds for local
algorithms for example and of course
there's statistical algorithms and you
could probably add
quite a bit to this list so
in other words the fact that coming that
these random
optimization problems turn out to be
rather challenging algorithmically
can actually be used to gain insights on
the limitations
of some of the algorithmic techniques
that we have come
to cherish
okay so that much for motivation um
there's any questions on motivation
any motivational problems i i guess i
i i would toss in a comment that
as as further contrarian-ness to add to
your contrarian-ness
random problems may be hard but they're
far from the hardest
problems of their size so a number of us
over the years have participated in
these
sat competitions throwing in various
random problems that we thought were had
clever
hiding and deceptive nature and they
were all beaten very easily by much
smaller problems that were
uh corresponded to cryptography or
problems in number theory and so on
right so i guess coming up with the
hardest problem of a specific
size is a hard problem in its own right
uh okay so now let me move on to
the second somewhat more technical part
and in this part i would like to share
with you
some of the recent or recent-ish
ideas and techniques that have been
discovered
in this area and that to a large extent
are inspired by by statistical physics
ideas
and um that go beyond
the classical combinatorics viewpoint
quite
a bit and so apart from the fact that
they are quite powerful i also think
that this
statistical physics point of view is
very aesthetic
and i hope i will be able to to share
some of my
enthusiasm with you the specific
optimization problem that i'm going to
speak about is
a fairly simple specimen of its kind
namely it's the max cup problem on
random regular graphs
so i'm going to look at a random d
regular graph on n vertices g and d
and the problem is the following i want
to assign
labels plus or minus 1 to the vertices
in such a way that the number of
edges that connect vertices with
different labels is
as large as possible and you might think
well
this problem should have been solved a
long time ago
it looks rather easy i mean it's a
random deregular graph i read about
random d regular graphs 20 years ago so
this must be an easy case
um i can probably look it up in my
random graphs book on my shelf
but it turns out to be rather more
challenging than
meets the eye at first glance maybe and
that is true both from a structural and
from an algorithmic
point of view um so before we
look at the physics perspective let's
briefly revisit
the classical combinatorics take on such
problems and how we would
have gone about them maybe 20 years ago
um about 17 years ago
uh so one idea that springs to mind is
of course to use
some kind of greedy algorithm
and to try and analyze this algorithm
try and trace this greedy algorithm in
order to
get an idea how big the maximum cut is
or more specifically in order to
obtain a lower bound on the number of
edges in a maximum cut
the first 3d algorithm that you might
try and
analyze is probably this one here greedy
algorithm
you simply pass over the vertices one by
one in one sweep
and so you never change your mind about
a vertex
and at every step you simply assign
the vertex that you handle currently
this spin um that is in the minority
amongst its neighbors
so some of the neighbors might still be
uncolored you ignore them
and amongst the ones that are colored
you choose the minority
spin and value pass through the vertices
and you simply
count the number of edges that
this algorithm is going to cut in the
end
this algorithm has been analyzed by
diastole
cerner and walmart in 2003 using the
method of differential equations and we
are going to see
the numbers that come out of it in a bit
it's not too difficult it's not trivial
either
you do have to do some non-trivial
fiddling with differential equations
but it's a fairly simple idea i would
say
so that's a lower bound we can trace
this algorithm see how many edges it
cuts
and certainly our random graph is going
to have to have as
many a cut off for the corresponding
size at least
how about the upper bound well the
classical idea going back to
addis in the 1940s or so would be to use
the first moment method you simply
calculate
the expected number of cuts in your
graph
that cut through a specific number of
edges
more precisely let's say that you want
to cut an alpha fraction of all the
edges
then you can calculate the number of the
expected number of
cuts where such an alpha fraction
crosses uh you yeah you
um play around with sterling's formula
for a while
and you arrive at this formula down here
you get something that is exponential in
n that is unsurprising because you have
two to the n cuts in total
and for each of these cuts you calculate
the probability that
it actually that there's actually alpha
dn on two crossing edges
the formula involves the binary entropy
function
h of alpha and when you plot
the exponent as a function of alpha you
see that it goes negative this is for d
equals three at
maybe 0.95 or so
so at this point
for this value of alpha value function
goes negative
the exponent here is negative which
means that the expected number of
cuts at this particular weight goes to
zero
exponentially in the limit of large n
so that means thanks to markov's
inequality
um that there's not going to be a cut
of weight greater than whatever this
year is 0.95 or so
we have probability tending to 1 as n
goes to infinity
and that means by simply using this
first moment calculation we get
an upper bound on the maximum cut size
so this was maybe roughly
the state of the art about 20 years ago
i don't know a reference for this
calculation
but it's pretty straightforward
so um right so now uh in the meantime we
learned how
physicists think about these problems
and
um their perspective is
um based on
yeah i mean based on something called
the partition function
and the boltzmann distribution to
introduce this you should think of the
vertices
of your graph as magnetic particles
that can carry one of two possible
magnetic spins plus one or minus one
and we
introduce an energy function so for any
assignment of plus or minus one spins to
our magnetic particles
we define an energy function which is
simply the number of
edges that connect two vertices
with the same spin in other words we
think of the edges
as interactions between magnetic
particles
and for some reasons our magnetic
particles have the property that they
prefer
the other particles they interact with
to be
to possess the opposite spin to carry
the opposite spin
so the hamiltonian the energy of a
configuration is simply the number of
monochromatic edges the number of edges
that connect two people with the same
spin
and for a given parameter beta which we
think of in the as inverse temperature
we then introduce
a probability distribution on such
magnetic configurations
this is called the boltzmann
distribution and it assigns a
probability mass that is proportional to
x of minus beta times energy
to a particular configuration
so the idea is that the sportsman
distribution is fairly
indifferent about your energy if beta is
small
in that case this yeah
this energy term here gets suppressed by
this beta factor
on the other hand as you make beta
bigger the boltzmann distribution is
going to shift
the bulk of its probability mass to
relatively good cuts to
configuration sigma that possess
only a small number of monochromatic
engines
and in order to ensure that you obtain a
probability measure in the end
we have to divide by normalizing terms
at
g beta which is called the partition
function and that is simply the sum of
all the
boltzmann weights of all the different
configurations so
that's that's an interesting idea i mean
um
it goes back a long time in physics of
course and
it's still for some reason pretty new to
combinatorialists
or to computer scientists at least every
time i speak to them
but we can see that there's close
connections between this viewpoint
and the maximum cut problem
and that is because you can
easily express the maximum cut on your
graph in terms of the partition function
to be precise you can you get the
maximum cut weight on your graph
and this doesn't hold just for random
graphics but this actually holds true
for
any given graph if you take the limit as
beta goes to infinity
of dn2 okay that's because
i think that that's just a fine shift
that we apply
plus the derivative with respect
to inverse temperature of the log of
your partition function
and so it's easy to check this formula
with pencil and paper but the idea the
intuition why this is true is simply
that
this derivative here when you do the
calculation turns out to be
the average weight of
the average number of edges that are cut
under a typical configuration sigma
that is drawn from your boltzmann
distribution so this derivative here in
other words is simply just
the average weight of a random cut at
this particular value of beta
and like i said as you make beta bigger
this probability mass
shifts to extremal cuts shifts to
maximum cuts in your graph
and that is why you get this limiting um
statement down here it's not difficult
to check by hand but
i mean that's kind of the what's going
on behind the scenes
and by the way if you um if you evaluate
this expression up here at beta equals
zero
uh you get a nice little um proof
that the average that the maximum cut
weight is at least half the
number of edges because for beta equals
zero your
boltzmann distribution is simply just a
uniform distribution on all the
two to the n possible spin assignments
okay so that's the boltzmann
distribution and
the partition function um by the way if
anybody is
unhappy because i'm either going too
fast or too slow
uh try to let me know somehow
uh right
uh okay great
now let's um i mean what i said on the
last
slide or two actually works for any
given graph now let's
revisit the situation of the random
regular graph
and let's try to gain some insight into
the first moment
calculation that we did and how that
compares to these
physics ideas so um
what i'm going to try and convince you
of is that the first moment calculation
effectively
labors under the assumption that there's
no long-range correlations going on in
our graph
so we can reasonably expect this first
moment calculation
that we conducted to give us
accurate results if and only if
there's no long-range correlations in
our in our random graph in our magnetic
system if you like
um so what do i mean by long-range
correlations well there's three
different ways of looking at it
um and i'm going to explain them in
increasing strength
the weakest most modest type of absence
of long-range correlations
or strongest way of saying that there's
no long-range correlations is something
called gibbs uniqueness
and of course those of you who are into
computational complexity i've heard a
lot about gibb's uniqueness
thanks to the work of alan sly and mike
sun and many others
about how gibbs uniqueness is
intertwined with the complexity
of counting and sampling so um what do i
mean by gibbs uniqueness
think of or look at a random d
ary tree where every vertex has d minus
one
children and um
think of a process where you
start from the root a broadcasting
process where you start from the root
and then you assign every child vertex
a random color given the color of
the parent vertex and we assign this
color in such a way that the local
interactions
as in our boltzmann distribution are
maintained
so depending on the value of beta your
child will
most more or less prefer to be
to take the opposite spin value if beta
is
infinity for example your children will
deterministically
take the opposite spin value if beta is
zero
they will be indifferent and just take a
random spin
now look at the configuration that you
get
once you play this game on the tree for
a large number of rounds for a large
step
and what we are asking ourselves is can
we
reconstruct from this boundary
configuration
the spin that we started from in other
words if we look at
the magnetic model the
spin system on this particular tree
what is the dependence between the spin
configuration on the boundary
and the spin configuration on the root
gibbs uniqueness expresses that there's
absolutely no correlation
as you make the number of levels the
number of layers in the tree bigger
so as the tree grows taller the boundary
completely decouples
from the root so no matter what boundary
condition you see here it will not allow
you to
recover the status of the root in a
non-trivial way
to you the root is i mean to you given
this boundary condition given any
boundary condition the spin at the root
is just
a coin toss
a slightly more modest a way of
saying that there's no long-range
correlations is something called
non-reconstruction
non-reconstruction you
don't consider a worst-case boundary
condition but you consider
a random boundary condition a typical
boundary condition generated by the
broadcasting process
so the route starts with a particular
spin for example blue the children
choose spins given the spin of their
parent
and depending on beta they have a
stronger or weaker preponderance to
take the opposite spin value and you
play this game for a while until you hit
the boundary at a large number l of
layers
and now you ask yourself for a typical
boundary produced by this broadcasting
process
is it possible to um tell what color we
started from or at least to
form a non-trivial guess as to the color
that we started from
if you can beat the odds and get
better by epsilon than a coin toss
then we say that the reconstruction
property holds otherwise we say that
there's non-reconstruction
and in this strong sense you have a
decoration
between the spin value at the root
and the set of all the spins of
the vertices at the bottom of the tree
at the boundary
and so this would be this would still be
a
pretty strong property but a lot weaker
than gibbs uniqueness because
um i mean as this tree grows stronger
there's actually quite a lot of possible
boundary conditions
um and in this case in the case of gibbs
uniqueness we require that
none of them gives you a clue as to the
spin of the route
in the case of non-reconstruction we
merely ask
that a typical boundary condition
a random boundary condition doesn't
reveal
or doesn't hint at the spin at the root
and finally there's something that the
most modest condition
that i would call static replica
symmetry
and so this actually at first glance
looks incredibly weak
and it simply says that in your random
graph
if you look at a configuration drawn
from
the boltzmann distribution
then the spins that you observe on the
first two vertices vertex number one and
vertex number two
are approximately independent so if i
tell
you i just observed spin red spin one
at vertex number one then that shouldn't
tell you anything about
what vertex number two does
so this looks pretty weak at first
glance because it doesn't
involve a lot of vertices like here or
like here
it only just involves two vertices
so and in fact in general it is a much
weaker property
in the random in the max cup problem on
random graphs you will see that actually
these three properties are equivalent
okay so um you have to average
over the vertices no what what are v1
and v2
right okay very good that's a good point
um
so i'm just taking v1 and v2
because they are as good as a random
pair
um so my random graph model is
completely invariant
under permutations of the vertices so if
the property holds for v1 and v2
then it actually also a typical pair of
random vertices we cannot ask that this
property hold for
any parallel vertices because for
example this won't be true
for a pair of vertices that are directly
connected to each other
or that are at a very short distance
it's simply not going to work because
in that case there's short-range
interactions
but um saying that it holds for two
randomly chosen vertices is actually
equivalent to this
and because two randomly chosen vertices
typically have a large distance
as big as log n or so it makes sense to
speak of
absence of long-range correlations if
this property holds
okay so now let's see how these short
how this absence of long range
correlations plays with the first moment
calculation
so let me uh try and do a first moment
calculation for my partition function
here
and let's assume that we have this
static replica symmetry property that
vertices that are that i mean a typical
pair of random vertices decouples
now here's a leap of faith if this
property holds for my
irregular graph then it might
also hold for sub graphs so
think of composing your random deregular
graph by
adding one edge at a time say you take
the red and the edges in a random order
and you first throw out all the edges
and then you put them back in one by one
then maybe we are in luck and this
absence of long-range correlations
extends to
all the subgroups that we visit along
the process
as we go maybe let's pretend
this is correct so now imagine that we
stick
in a new edge how much is that going to
change the value of my partition
function
well if i stick in the new edge then i
get
my partition function is going to shift
by
one if
the edge happens to be bichromatic
under a configuration under a specific
configuration
and it's going to change by e to the
minus beta for
the contribution is going to change by e
to the minus beta for configurations
where the two vertices that the edge
connects are colored the same
and um if i'm assuming that this edge
connects two vertices that used to be
far apart
basically a pair of random vertices then
this term this probability term here
will be approximately a half
so i would expect that the change in
partition function is going to be
approximately 1 plus e to the minus beta
on
2. and so
if this if the static replica symmetry
property holds then i'm led to believe
that maybe my partition function or more
precisely the log of my partition
function
takes this very simple value log 2 plus
d
over 2 for the number of edges
times this term here so i have d n over
2 edges that's why i'm collecting this
term here
dn over 2 times and log 2 because
that's the starting value that's that
corresponds to the
partition function value 2 to the n of
the empty graph
and in fact it turns out that this
expression here is precisely
the first moment of my partition
function
so the absence of long-range
correlations is what i believe
should be my partition function value
so sorry the absence of long-range
relations leads me to believe that my
partition function would actually be
close to its first moment
and um yeah and in fact you can
use this first moment argument in order
to get bound on the maximum cut value so
if
the absence of long-range correlations
holds then you can
use this formula here to get the bound
on the maximum cut value
and it turns out that that bound is
precisely identical
to the bound that we obtained from the
naive first moment calculation
okay wonderful but of course
it could very well be that actually in
our problem there's long-range
correlations
and actually the static replica symmetry
doesn't hold and that instead we have
something that our good friends from
physics call
replica symmetry breaking
to explain this think of
your hamiltonian this
energy function as a
function on this high dimensional cube
plus minus 1 to the n that gives you
some kind of a real value for each
possible configuration this picture here
on the left
is my attempt at drawing this function
and think of tuning beta
as going through this function in a
vertical
axis and taking a cross-section of this
function at a particular height
if you take a cross-section at a high
level for a small value of beta where
you are pretty indifferent
to energy and say to yourself well i'm
i'm happy with um moderately good
cuts then um it is reasonable
to think that what you are getting your
cross section is going to be
a more or less contiguous piece
and so maybe one of the components of
this picture maybe this big component
here in the middle
will and for example a markov chain
would have an easy time walking around
on this space
and conceivably this might mean that
there's no long-range correlations going
on
on the other hand if you make beta
bigger you're going to
cut this landscape here at a much lower
level
and so you're going to cut through many
of these
many of these troughs and therefore you
might end up with a
very disconnected picture
and in this disconnected picture which
basically
indicates that there's some local
clusters of good cuts that are separated
from one another
in this very disconnected picture maybe
you will have different components
and these
the existence of these different
components might induce long-range
correlations
that is because if i tell you the
spin-off valve of vertex number one
you might get a hint out of this in
which component i am
in which component my configuration
suits
maybe spin maybe
vertex number one has a strong
likelihood of being
spin one in this component down here or
maybe in this one down here
and maybe in this component vertex
number two
is strongly favors for example
the value minus one in that case um
because of this hidden parameter namely
the cluster the pure state
in physics jargon that i'm sitting in
these correlations these long-range
correlations might occur
so the hidden parameter the if you like
index of the cluster
might induce correlations there's this
hidden variable
that somehow coordinates with spins
and in that case we cannot expect the
first moment calculation to be accurate
because as i add more edges
there's more correlations going on and
so i'm more likely
uh to hit um to have to pay this penalty
factor of e to the minus beta
in other words in this case the first
moment bound
is somehow too generous it gives away
too much and
actually my maximum cut value should be
a lot smaller
and as we are speaking about replica
symmetry breaking there's actually
different brands of replica symmetry
breaking that can be
separated by the overlap distribution by
how two typical configurations from the
boltzmann distribution
compare in the radical symmetric case
then
typical then the spins of typical
vertices are independent
i would expect the following to go on
suppose i draw
two independent samples from my
boltzmann distribution
because of the inherent symmetry of the
problem
because i can just swap pluses and
minuses
i know that the average spin value of
every vertex is just zero
and if there's no long-range
correlations going on
i would tend to believe that
the inner product of two such random
configurations
configurations should be zero because um
if i if there's no long range
correlations going on then
essentially the values of the spins are
independent they average to zero
so the inner product should be
concentrated about zero
in other words true typical samples as
plus minus one vector should be
approximately orthogonal
and in that case we are in this left
picture here
where the empirical distribution of the
overlap concentrates about zero
the second scenario is that i basically
that i have many different components
potentially but all these components
look internally essentially the same
they are separated from one another
but if i take a look at one particular
component
structurally it looks just like any
other
there's some i mean there's different
components but the components are
essentially symmetric
they look very much alike and this is
something that we would call one step
replica symmetry breaking in this case i
would expect to see
uh two or actually three different
overlap values three because the problem
is symmetric under swapping plus and
minus one
one possibility is that i draw two true
configurations from different components
in which case
they would probably still be orthogonal
because
of the inherent symmetry of the problem
because on the average
the spins are zero but then i might get
different overlap values for example i
might get an overlap value very close to
one
if i managed to draw two configurations
that lie
in the same component in that case they
might have a lot in common so the
overlap might be close to one
or minus one again because of symmetry
reasons
and the final scenario might be
something called full replica symmetry
breaking
in which case i get a hierarchy of
different components
so the this picture here is actually too
crude to express that i would get
components nested inside components
nested inside components and so on and
so forth
and so in that case
my overlap distribution could
potentially be
something continuous
because of this hierarchical nested
structure of the components i think you
might have heard about this
in another talk before but these are
basically
the three different scenarios of overlap
that we are we are looking at
and so the replica symmetric assumption
that corresponds to the first moment
calculation only
is described by the first one
okay so now let's uh let's see what we
can
tell about this problem we are going to
look at this quantity here called the
free energy which is basically
the uh average of the logarithm of the
partition function
and we are going to compare this value
with the expectation outside
the log with the corresponding quantity
with the expectation inside the log
and the first theorem here tells us that
this assumption of replica symmetry
which leads to
the notion that i can swap the log and
the expectation
is tied up to a specific value of up to
a specific
threshold of beta and fails to be tight
for larger values of beta
this threshold value of beta is actually
displayed here in blue
that's these blue dots as a function of
d so uh
yeah let's let me um sketch a little bit
how the proof of this theorem works
or maybe how it doesn't work
uh right so let me skip this a little
bit
okay so your first attempt at solving
this problem might be to conduct a
second moment calculation i mean we did
the first moment we might do the second
moment too
and if you set up a naive second moment
calculation you would sum
on all possible pairs of spin
configurations
and you would look at their contribution
to
the square of the partition function
and this value here the number of
edges that are cut by these two
configurations turns out to depend
on the overlap of these two
configurations on the inner product of
these two configurations
so we reorder the sum according to
overlap
some on all possible pairs of
configurations with that overlap
and like in the first moment calculation
we can actually write
a specific analytic function that
explains the second moment so in order
to work out the second moment we have to
work out the maximum
contribution to this sum here the
maximum
overlap contribution and that can be
expressed by
this function here which again involves
the binary entropy
so
if this function takes
its maximum at zero which means that the
zero overlap the orthogonal overlap
dominates
then we see that actually the second
moment is of the same order as the
square of the first moment
in which case we can dust off our
routine concentration inequalities
and we can show that the typical value
of the partition function is actually
close to the
expectation of the partition function
close to the first moment
in the case of the max cut problem
interestingly
this turns out to be correct up to a
specific value of beta
which is strictly smaller than the value
of beta that i promised you in the
theory
at the value of beta that i promised you
in the theorem
actually this magical function this
second moment function has a local
minimum at zero
it's not that there's another local
maximum but actually there's a local
minimum at zero
so the second moment unfortunately
doesn't suffice to solve this problem
so let's briefly reflect why that is
there's a good combinatorial reasons
reason for it namely
if you follow the same path on the
arduino random graph
you discover that the first and the
second moment
work out to be the same however
the threshold where your replica
symmetry breaking
phase transition occurs
actually happens earlier on the error
training mode
on the errors rainy model you actually
get
this phase transition occur at a smaller
value at this value beta star of d plus
one
where this function here flips from
having a max to having a min
so on the average rating model our
second moment
calculation gives a tight result
and because the formulas work out the
same it cannot possibly be true that the
second moment method works
on the random regular graph because
otherwise you would get something that
is too good
on the edit reading graph too good to be
true
so that's funny um
what do we do so how do we
how do we get around this problem with
the second moment method how do we
use some physics insight in order to
improve on the second moment method can
we use something else something inspired
by
the boltzmann distribution what we
can maybe somehow use this spatial
mixing property
that i spoke about so what we can do is
we can
use the something called the planted
model
which is a random graph model that you
obtain by flipping the omelette on the
other side instead of
first drawing a graph and then a
configuration in the planted model you
first draw a configuration
and then you draw a graph to match your
configuration and
specifically what i mean by this is that
you first draw
a spin assignment uniformly at random
and then you draw a deregular graph in
such a way that the probability of a
specific graph coming up
is proportional to e to the minus beta
number
of monochromatic edges of this
particular configuration
under your graph
so
with a bit of algebra you can check that
the following is true the probability
that a random graph drawn from this
distribution has a particular property
is proportional to the first moment
times the indicator that your normal
random regular graph has this property
so
this planted model opens up a way of
indirectly doing moment calculations on
the plane model uh
and another connection is that in this
planted model
the local structure of your graph is
actually precisely described
by the broadcasting process that i
mentioned earlier in the context of the
non-reconstruction problem
namely locally this planted model
resembles exactly
the tree that is produced by the
broadcasting process
and therefore we can use an interesting
result
from the classical analysis of such
broadcasting processes
that tells us that the
non-reconstruction threshold for this
broadcasting process
on this particular tree is precisely
this threshold beta star that i promised
in the theory so
um as a result
because we work in the planted model
because we have this particular local
tree structure
we can reduce from the spatial mixing
result from the non-reconstruction
result we can now
use our knowledge of the boltzmann
distribution
we can deduce that in your planted model
actually
the typical overlap of two spin
configurations
is close to zero typically
spin configurations are orthogonal
and we can now use this knowledge in
order to
improve upon the second moment
calculation
namely we can say well you know what
simply just look at this event here at
the event that your
overlap is orthogonal is that two
typical spin configurations are
orthogonal
condition your random graph on having
this property
and then given this property conduct a
second moment calculation
so you do a truncated second moment
calculation
given the information about the overlap
that you learned
in the planted model
because you are effectively conditioning
on the overlap being orthogonal being
zero
the problem with this funny function
that it has a min at zero and
takes bigger values elsewhere disappears
because now you
only ever have to evaluate your function
at zero so
this trick here arguing via the planted
model
and using spatial mixing and the overlap
does away
with the difficulties of the second
moment calculation
and with this truncation we are actually
in a position to show
that your partition function is at least
at least as big
as the first moment formula with high
probability
i mean i have a question can you tell us
how did you argue the second bullet
the second bullet this one yeah that's
just from the definition of the planted
model
that is because in the planted model i
use this particular construction here
from this construction this is immediate
actually i see yeah it's just a few
lines of algebra yes but it's a good
problem
so uh right so that proves the first
part of my theory
how about the second part well for the
second part
i use another observation about the
planted model namely that
the logarithm of the partition function
is tightly concentrated about its
expectation and therefore if
the typical value of log z
is close to the first moment then this
rescaling
in the planted model the fact that i
prefer things that are
graphs that are good for this particular
spin configuration
doesn't induce much of a shift
and therefore if the first moment
calculation gives the right result
then my random plane random graph is
close to the
planted model
and from this i can get a contradiction
namely
if i can show that the typical value of
the partition function in the planted
model
is bigger than my first moment bound
then this assumption here that the
typical value of the partition function
is closer to the first moment
cannot possibly be valid
as a result we just in order to complete
the proof of
theory we just need to study the planted
model again
and it turns out that studying the
planted model is a fundamentally easier
task than studying the plain random
graph model
and that is because of a fundamental
result that the planted model
is always replica symmetric
so we can use some calculations that
were done
on the basis of replica symmetry in
order to get a result about replica
symmetry breaking
in the planted model
so right
so um we can use this formula for the
free energy in the planted model
in order to get a result about the plane
random graph model
and um
so using a bit of calculus we can
actually get a good estimate of the free
energy in the plant model and show
that in fact the free energy in the
planted model is
too big um for the planted model and the
plain random graph model to be
similar above and beyond this
particular threshold of beta
i'm running a bit out of time i
apologize but
so what i just wanted to demonstrate is
this
alternative to the second moment
calculation that uses
the planted model the fact that the
planted model is replica symmetric
and the idea of using spatial mixing
properties in order to study
the planted model which i believe can be
used in
some other examples too
okay so um i was going to speak about
the interpolation method as well but i'm
going to skip this part
i'll just close with this table here
which shows the bounds that you can
on the maximum cut value that you can
get
out of the hypothetical out of dropping
the hypothesis
that your random graph model is replica
symmetric so once you are willing to
bite the bullet and accept that
presumably replica symmetry this
long-range decorrelation property
doesn't hold
you can come up with better bounds that
are strictly
smaller than the first moment bound and
obtain these particular numbers here on
the maximum cut value
down below on the bottom line you see
what the greedy algorithm that i
mentioned
a while ago gives
on the top you see the classical first
moment bound
and in the middle you see the bounce
that you get from
the one-step radical symmetry breaking
hypothesis
which may or may not be entirely
accurate in the maximum cut probe
okay so here's an outlook slide with
a few open problems and some
other known results so
the first thing i should mention is that
actually for the max cut drop
on random regular graphs we have a
precise variational formula
that tells you how to find the maximum
cut value
or what what the maximum cut value is
unfortunately
so this is some work with bill perkins
from
last year unfortunately this variational
formula
is totally intransparent
i don't know a way of getting numbers
out of it
but in principle we have an expression
that gives you the precise maximum cut
value
if you make d bigger if you take the
value of
the degree of your graph to infinity
your model actually approaches
a somewhat in my opinion simpler model
called the sharing kirkpatrick model
which compares to the random deregular
graph a bit like
the central limit theorem convert and
compares to
discrete probability distributions
you get we know at this point the proof
of the precise monarch b
formula for the free energy in the k
ni sub model and also that this formula
eventually breaks down
and here's a bunch of open problems that
i that i like and that you will have to
google
thank you for your attention
okay we're we're a little bit over time
but uh
those who wish to can hang out and
ask i mean some questions until he goes
to bed
so any questions for me
i have one question
hi thank you for the nice talk so
you you mentioned that um sorry i have
to formulate my question um
yeah the planted model is in general oh
sorry the planting model
is replica symmetric uh
is it a general statement or is it
specific to this
max cut problem yeah so let me level
with you
what i said is not not actually true
so the planted model is replica
symmetric
so so one of the one of my favorite
tricks in life is
a stirring so if you if you
have a cup of tea and you add some sugar
it won't get sweet you have to stir
and it's similar in these models here as
well so
the planted model by itself is like the
cup of tea with the sugar
at the bottom and you have to stir it a
little bit
to make it replicasymmetric by which i
mean that you
for example one thing that you could do
is you could
pin a few vertices to their specific
planted spins
and then as a result of this slight
perturbation the model is going to get
replica symmetric for all i know it
might be replicas symmetric to begin
with but there's a few cases
a few crit there might be a few critical
values of the degree and of beta where
actually this pinning is necessary
um but as a general fact with the
pinning operation applied
a planted model will always become
replicas symmetric
so you say if you if you try to ping um
to the original model it might not work
this
aiming strategy so the pinning strategy
would work with the original model as
well
except that you in order to pin
correctly you need access to a sample
from the boltzmann distribution
and in fact in um
a way a good part of the
boltzmann distribution so the pinning
basically in my mind
i may be wrong but in my mind it roughly
corresponds to putting your finger on
one of these components
you're basically telling the model you
know what just go into this component
and forget about the others
maybe i could ask a follow-up question
to the pinning question
um could could something stronger be
true in the planted model that if you
pin
you actually have exponential decay of
correlations in on the random graph
yeah i don't know um
yeah i don't know i mean it's it seems
difficult to connect um
the uh it seems difficult to connect the
uh
pinning operation with spatial
properties like actually
yeah what happens as you as you move
away from the vertex if that's what you
mean
i mean just you're sort of picking one
of the gibbs states but maybe
these gibbs states actually have real
exponential decay of correlations
in the planted model yeah uh
i wouldn't count on it so there's one
example that we looked at
which is actually a random matrix a
linear problem
uh it's the simple simplest random
matrix model you can think of
you just take a n by n random matrix
over f two
and you put in every uh you put in one
in every entry of volatility over n
independently
and so so actually jane looked at this
model
together with me as well at some point
and if you make d
greater than e um it turns out that this
model behaves in a funny way
that it has two pure states which are
approximately the same weight
or that it could have that it could go
one of two ways in some funny sense
um so yeah
i don't know this might be a counter
example it may not be i don't know i'm
not sure but once once you pan
don't you pick one of those yeah exactly
yeah i'm not sure so i'm just saying
this this could be
i would have to think about it yeah for
that particular problem
actually this e does have a
combinatorial
interpretation it's for the algorithm
where you just
uh recursively pull out degree of
water and what's made right and then and
that's the
place where the remaining graph is not
empty but i don't know
it responds to this shape of of two
maximum
yeah that's exactly what's going on so
what happens is if you
so what happens is you could be in a
situation where
a fairly small number of variables are
actually frozen to zero
and then you pin a little bit more
and all of a sudden a very much larger
number of variables freeze
so that doesn't mean that that the other
contribution is tiny
it's not that tiny because the part that
you additionally freeze had very little
entropy
um there's a question from jeff zoo who
i have
jeff can you unmute yourself oh yeah
oh hi i mean i just wonder what you were
looking for when you say
a better mess within the open problem
oh yeah yeah i mean it wouldn't be
wonderful to have
this one of these approximate message
passing
algorithms work that do so well on the
sk model
uh but i remember that there is an
argument in that paper that
says that it already works maybe i
remember that wrong
this is for growing uh degree it's like
it's
it might work sorry for jumping in but
it's likely because of the connection of
mark scott
and sk which exists for degree
uh increasing but let's say if you take
degree
g equal to four it's not clear what's a
good competitor for algorithm
this and it's not it's not clear to me
even
if i should think that the model leaps
right into
full rsb or whether there's maybe i mean
in max cut
that might be conceivable but in other
problems there might be
a phase where the problem is one step
rsp for a while before it
leaps into full rsb as far as i'm as far
as i'm aware
so in that case um an algorithm that
tries to serve the wave
of a full rsb might have a hard time i
don't know
okay thanks and so so
the variational formula you referred to
earlier in your work with will
that that does not assume one rsb that
can handle
yeah we never want to meet that formula
particularly at night
so it's it's it's a pretty complicated
it's actually it's it's
an extension of a formula that dimitri
panchenko obtained
for adulth models
and it basically optimizes over a space
of probability measures on the space of
probability measures on
zero one that have to satisfy a
particular fixed point property
so yeah i don't think it's particularly
useful so one of the major open problems
in this area i think
is to come up with a version of ultra
metricity that works in these problems
because that might actually dramatically
simplify the types of variational
formulas that we get
so there is a there is a proposal in
physics
maybe from two years ago uh by um
by a postdoc of giorgio his last name is
conchetti
and he has these two papers that propose
a formula that is of the form uh that is
a
basically an analog of the parisi
formula for uh
for uh sparse for sparse models
i don't know if he looks at that or if
you can say anything about that i don't
know if you guys
are familiar with that work yeah i i
haven't looked at it i mean there's some
work by dimitri panchenko as well where
he tried to do something
um but i i think there's still some way
off of
actually proving that
it's a good question so the difference
there between
uh dimitri's formula is that so
yeah you can consider this hierarchy of
optimizing over
probably distributions over probably
distribution and so forth
but this other formula circumvents that
so they had he has a way that i don't
understand yet fully but he has a way of
having a variational formula that
considers stochastic processes instead
of considering probably distribution
over over
et cetera et cetera in this way but yeah
i can't understand it yet
yes it's yeah i haven't personally
looked into
it um seriously
yeah but i think it's one of the one of
the
best open problems in this area albeit
probably one of the hardest to
yeah i mean regarding these deborah
butcher conjecture
there is a new preprint by like mizell
sorkin and someone named amin kojo
auglin
that appears to address this that came
out
today but is that only a boundary the
stuff that i spoke about in this talk
um i think so the
i mean the general this conjecture makes
a connection between mean min bisection
and max cut
and so if you look at the cavity
equations of course they
look compellingly similar
in fact both of these you can easily
connect to
the bianna bray model
and so it's yeah i mean that's that's
why they conjecture that if you sum the
max cut and the min by section you get
what the number of edges
so we tried i mean ville and i tried to
get
that conjecture out of our beautiful
variational formula
and out of our beta state decomposition
for a while
but we yeah it wasn't a big success
let's say
i mean again it looks like i mean so the
good thing about this conjecture is that
you can potentially prove it without
um without calculating the max cut value
or the min by section value
without getting a handle on it right and
so
for example one one question that
is yeah
one other one more modest open problem
would be to show
that on a random regular graph
a maximum cut or a good cut for large
beta
a typical cut for large beta would be
balanced
so if you if you could show that the sum
of the spins is little of n
that would be a good step towards this
conjecture
and i mean that that yeah seems like a
very reasonable
thing to believe but uh yeah
all right we're a bit over time here um
there is a social hour such as it is in
uh about an hour are there any more
questions for amin
before we release him to the tender
mercies of his family
all right well i mean it was really
wonderful to have this talk from you i
hope to see you again soon
ideally with actual photons so thank you
very much